il est 6 heures du matin dans cette
favela de rio de janeiro quand 200
policiers lancent une opération
anti-drogue rapidement des coups de feu
sont échangés un policier est tué d'une
balle dans la tête
l'intervention tourne alors au carnage
selon des habitants de cette favela de
40000 personnes perdues blessent des
passagers présents dans le métro aérien
qui longe la favela au moins 29
personnes vont trouvé la mort au cours
des 9 heures qu'a duré la sauce ce jeudi
6 mai c'est le bilan humain le plus
élevé jamais enregistré pour une telle
opération à reduce militariste et rise
in tout comme les métis l'ath'liv des
six marqués du nom il ajouté ça spect in
christ sécurité selon la police
l'opération qui préparait depuis 10 mois
visait un puissant groupe de trafiquants
accusé de recruter des enfants et des
adolescents
dans cette vidéo les autorités locales
montrent leur saisi plusieurs pistolets
et fusils et grenades ainsi que
d'importantes quantités de drogue au
moins trois trafiquants visés ont été
abattus ce match de coupe contre les
trafiquants qui fait rage depuis 1995 la
police militaire de rio a perdu plus de
3000 hommes dans la guerre contre le
crime
rio de janeiro est la deuxième plus
grande ville du brésil avec 6 7 millions
d'habitants
c'est trois fois plus que paris à rio
chaque jour neuf personnes seraient
victimes
six volontaires et trois personnes
seraient tués par la police d'être à
paris à la guerre alessandri hockey au
moratoire le pipe au brio de nombreuses
familles habitant du quartier de
jacarezinho où a eu lieu l'assaut nous
demander justice pour les victimes des
agissements des accords justice pas de 5
à 8 6 alors concernés police tu resteras
ce titre remove du fort de france eq
analystes à dassa la société solving
joignent au mouvement bâle bâle il ya
konan bedie ne soit procédé à la tête
est mort